bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero el
fallecimiento de isabel segunda el
pasado 8 de septiembre ha puesto en
relevancia a algunos de sus legados
simbólicos y políticos que ha dejado en
más de 70 años de reinado entre ellos
destaca especialmente el fortalecimiento
de la commonwealth o mancomunidad de
naciones una organización internacional
que agrupa al reino unido- y algunas de
sus antiguas colonias que ha sido
fundamental para este antiguo imperio
desde mediados del siglo 20 en france24
repasamos su historia los inicios de lo
que se comenzó a llamar como
commonwealth datan de las primeras
décadas del siglo 20 para esos años
reinó unido- era una potencia imperial y
algunas personalidades políticas
consideraban que era importante otorgar
a sus colonias un estatus de
independencia o semi independencia que
les permitiera autogestionarse sin salir
del paraguas de control británico pero
su formación no se pudo dar hasta 1931
en un contexto de crecientes
sentimientos nacionalistas entre las
colonias y de crisis global reino unido-
se centró en crear una organización que
permitiera metrópoli conservar lazos
políticos ante posibles independencias y
mantener un círculo comercial que
hiciera que su economía sufriera menos
la inestabilidad del momento una
estrategia que todavía cobró más
relevancia tras el final de la segunda
guerra mundial tras la contienda reino
unido- ya no tenía la capacidad política
militar y económica para mantener su
vasto imperio y comenzó a ver a la
mancomunidad de naciones como su única
salida para intentar mantener cierta
relevancia internacional algo de lo que
isabel que por aquel entonces era la
heredera al trono era consciente así
hablaba la futura soberana sobre esta
organización en 1947
si avanzamos todos juntos con una fe
inquebrantable gran valor y buen corazón
seremos capaces de hacer de la
commonwealth que todos amamos tanto en
inglés algo aún más libre próspero feliz
y con una influencia más poderosa para
el bien del mundo
con su llegada al trono 1952 isabel
decidió invertir una gran cantidad de
tiempo en fortalecer sus relaciones con
las colonias que se estaban
independizando sin importar si seguía
siendo reina de esas naciones o no uno
de los puntos que más favorecieron el
crecimiento de esta organización
internacional es que los países que la
conformarán no tenían la necesidad de
reconocer al monarca británico como jefe
de estado aunque esta figura si es la
cabeza de la organización
como se observa en este mapa hasta 54
países independientes o semi
independientes forman parte de la
mancomunidad de naciones de los cuales
todos menos ruanda y mozambique tienen
lazos culturales e históricos con reino
unido y en todo este tiempo solamente 2
irlanda y zimbabue han salido de la
organización una unión que sin lugar a
dudas ha sido fundamental para reino
unido durante décadas esta organización
promovió fuertes lazos comerciales entre
sus miembros y acaparó grandes
porcentajes de exportaciones e
importaciones para reino unido aunque no
tiene un carácter vinculante para los
estados miembros esta organización ha
intentado mantener una postura firme con
la defensa de la democracia y los
derechos humanos durante décadas
llegando a suspender a algunos de sus
miembros como sudáfrica o pakistán por
eventos como el apartheid o golpes de
estados autoritarios sin embargo su
funcionalidad ha sido criticada en más
de una ocasión debido al carácter
neocolonial que tiene para algunos de
los habitantes de las antiguas colonias
durante los últimos años de reinado
segunda su hijo el ahora rey carlos
tercero ha intentado reforzar la
importancia de esta organización de la
que ya es su líder
señoras y señores ruego que esta reunión
de jefe de gobierno de la commonwealth
no solo revitalice los lazos entre
nuestros países sino que también dé a la
commonwealth una renovada relevancia
para todos sus ciudadanos
problems and giving life encontrando
soluciones prácticas a sus problemas y
dando vida a sus aspiraciones como en
red al hacerlo la commonwealth puede ser
una piedra angular en la vida de futuras
generaciones como lo ha sido para tanto
de nosotros pueden venir más pero esto
no será fácil para nuevo monarca ya que
algunas voces dentro de la organización
han expresado su disconformidad con que
el nuevo rey lidere la commonwealth las
críticas sobre el rol de la monarquía en
los países donde todavía sigue teniendo
presencia como australia canadá o nueva
zelanda y sobre el carácter neocolonial
que puede llegar a tener una
organización como la commonwealth han
crecido en los últimos años
aumentar tras la muerte de isabel
segunda aunque para muchos apartar a la
monarquía de su rol protagónico no tiene
por qué significar terminar con la
mancomunidad de naciones hay a efe creo
que es el momento de que canadá empiece
a concretar su salida de la monarquía no
podemos seguir en la commonwealth pero
ya no necesitamos la monarquía y ha
causado suficientes problemas es una
cuestión muy delicada para reino unido
especialmente en un momento en el que
sus relaciones con otras organizaciones
que en el pasado han sido fundamentales
para su economía como la unión europea
se han visto afectadas por el break si
algo a lo que hay que sumar el golpe
simbólico que supondría para una
institución como la monarquía que es
bien aceptada en reino unido pero que
cada vez es más cuestionada en otros
territorios con esto concluimos gracias
por compartir y comentar estas historias
que las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]